AVALANCHE TEAM.
>> Peter: MOSE T GET
THE WAS YOUNG.
I WATCHED THOUSANDS OF HOC FIGHA
HERE IS KAPRIZOV SO DYNAMIC.
HOW HE FOULS
TRIES TO GET ANYTHING.DONALD PLS
CONO
BURAKOVSKY.
TO LANDESKOG. PASSES
LATER AND THE AVALANCHE GET THE
1-0 LEAD.
KNOCKED OFF OF KADRI.
MAKAR AT THE RIGHT POINT.T.ALLO.
TH4-1-0.
THE AVS AND THEN WAS OKAY.
AND THE GAME HE WAS OKAY.JOHNSO.
HARTMAN OVER THE YEARS HAS HAD
BIG GAMES.
SHOWED YOU EVERYTHING HE BRINGS
TO THE AVALANCHE.ON?CK.
RIGHT THERE HE BLOCKIN.
DUMBA.
OUT TO FOLIGNO PLAYER HAS FOLIG
TURNED INTO?
AND HE
SCORES.
ERIK JOHNSON FROM
I MEANTHERE IS SOMETHING.
LONG SHOT DOWN TO THE  HAD ONE
CHANCE.
AND AVALANCHE.
THAT IS NATHAN MACKINNON AT H
SCORE!
NAZEM KADRI FROM ABOVE FIRES
GAMES.
ONE GOAL TO START THE SEASON.
AND NOW BACKK ON NET.
JASON MEGNA IS ONPUCK DID NOT C.
YOU SEE HE IS GOING  BACK OF
THE NET THE AVS GABE LANDESKOG.